is one of the top evaluators in the
national football league
and he has been around one of the uh the
greatest um
content providers the nfl or any sports
or any media company has ever put out
their nfl films
greg cosell back here on the rich eisen
show how are you greg
rich it's so good to be with you how are
you doing i am uh i'm excited
uh it's draft month greg one month from
today
we will actually have the uh entire
first round puzzle
already put together so many questions
being answered
um let's start with your evaluation of
the quarterback class and who do you
have
at the top of your quarterback class
rung
right now greg cosell you know it's
funny i i watched
a lot of these guys very early in the
process pretty much right after the nfl
season ends and then i went back and
looked at a little bit more
uh which i kind of do every year and uh
i think trevor lawrence would probably
still
be at the head of my class but the more
i watched
zach wilson the more i'm very very
intrigued now i don't think he's at the
level i've heard some say
he's aaron rodgers he's patrick mahomes
i don't think he's at
that level but there's something about
the looseness in his body he's got a
live arm not a power arm like he doesn't
have an arm like let's say matthew
stafford
but he's got a live loose arm he's
very loose with his body he moves
extremely well
as you know rich no quarterback comes
into the nfl a finished
product so when you talk about things
that are questions
they're questions it doesn't mean they
can't do it now he only was in one game
this year
in an environment that he'll face far
more often in the nfl
and that was against coastal carolina
where he faced fairly consistent
pressure
and did not handle himself particularly
well now that doesn't mean he won't
handle himself well
as we go forward and he plays in the
league but that's a question
but uh i i would say overall lawrence
would probably still
be uh my guy at the top well i mean
again
the the fact that you are um
even close to equivocating on this greg
means that zach has
clearly got a skill set that is
uh that is um something else
so um
[Music]
i think that that comes to from the fact
that uh
look you know what i do i watch the tape
i've actually been around trevor
lawrence yes
and he's a terrific kid but i've not
been around zach wilson so i couldn't
speak to that right uh
uh but i think there was a sense of
lawrence
and and this doesn't concern me when i
watch tape as you know rich because you
know what i do
but there was a sense that lawrence was
generational and i think people
started with that as their standard so
anything less than talking about him in
that way
meant that oh my god what's wrong
something's wrong here
right i don't i didn't start there i
just put the tape on
and i think that trevor lawrence is a
very good prospect
he's got high level traits in many areas
but i i
i would not i did not come away from
watching his tape and by the way
i watched eight games in 2019 and eight
games in 2020 right so i watched 16
full games i did not come away watching
trevor lawrence
tape thinking that he was generational i
came away thinking this kid's a good
prospect with higher level traits well i
mean generational
is what's been you know thrown in his
direction and
you know urban meyer is not just you
know uh scratching an
itch just for the sake of it you know i
mean he's
he's coming into the nfl because he
knows trevor lawrence is going to be his
quarterback and
right so um what are what are your
question marks about
trevor lawrence then greg um i think
there's
one in particular and again now you have
to see how it plays out in the nfl
trevor lawrence is is a little bit of
a body thrower he's a strider and if you
look at which i did
very carefully at the playoff games he's
been in over the last two years
when he gets pressure up the middle
because he's a strider and because he
throws with his body
he's not a short strider he he steps
into it
um and he gets his body into his throws
he tends to rush his mechanics when
there's pressure
in his face inside and when he rushes
his mechanics
he tends to get a little scatter shot
and inaccurate
now there might be games where you go
through a whole game and you don't face
that kind of pressure in a given game
there might be a game where you face
that pressure on seven or eight throws
every game is different every game plays
out differently
but that's something that i think is is
again a question
these are not situations where you're
saying oh he can't play in the league
he's no good
it's a question the tape told me it's a
question
greg cosell senior producer nfl films
and of course nfl
match up right here on the rich eisen
show so you've you've
you're you're high on wilson to the
point where
you're you're you're saying that
probably lawrence is a better prospect
coming out
of college so walk me through the
evaluation you think the jets are doing
right now
with sam darnold and zach wilson yeah
that's a great question because it's
easy after three years and we've
discussed sam darnold you and i
yes to say that arnold did not meet
expectations and maybe there's many
reasons for that so we might know some
we don't know
uh but if you're the jets it would seem
to me
that you would have to believe that zach
wilson
is far far better than sam darnold
within the context of your new offense
with the new coach
who is essentially bringing in the kyle
shanahan offense
because if you just believe that zach
wilson is just maybe
incrementally better than sam darnold i
don't know
again i i i don't know what they're
going to do but you would have to
believe wilson's significantly better
uh donald was a consensus top pick in a
draft there were people who thought he'd
be the number one tick
it hasn't gone well there were concerns
about darnold coming out
those concerns have been manifested over
the last number of years
so we'll see what the jets do my guess
is and and this factors into the
equation rich and you know this
if you draft zach wilson you you start
the clock again
whereas if you draft if you don't draft
a quarterback and sam donald your guy
you know what it's going to be in new
york if sam darnold let's say has a poor
first half
week one you know how that goes whereas
you you restart the clock with
zach wilson no i know you don't want to
maybe saddle a new coaching staff new
regime with that sort of pressure or
possibility of of occurring and then
you're you're right the next step is the
proverbial lulu
so what is your evaluation though what
is your evaluation of wilson to darnold
with your evaluation of darnold coming
out and having seen three years
even though admittedly uh darnold has
not had the consistency
uh in terms of talent and of course also
in terms of coaching
surrounding him the last three years
what's your evaluation of what the jets
are going through
i mean i think donald has has
essentially been
relatively the same player he was coming
out he's a big
physical athletic kid a good arm uh some
inconsistency with his ball placement
which stems from his lower body
mechanics
capable of making plays outside the
structure of of the offense but also
loses vision at times when he gets
outside the structure of the offense
and can make some poor throws so there's
a lot to like and a few concerns
with darnold and those concerns have
shown up over the last three years
just as they did with his college tape i
think that
uh zach wilson is a is a little smaller
i would say his arm is looser and
livelier
darnold has a good arm but i would say
wilson's arm is looser and livelier
i think he's an easier mover uh just the
way in which he moves they're both
capable of making plays
outside of structure uh wilson was
his senior tape his 2020 tape in
particular he was a very comfortable
player
because he rarely faced pressure so
that's the part of
of wilson's game even though he's a very
good mover
and can make plays outside of structure
he did not face much pressure
and you have to wait and see how that
will play out once he's in the nfl
greg cosell here on the rich eisen show
so uh we've established you the your top
two
who's next you got three more
first-round great quarterbacks that
we're all talking about what do you got
for me on that
to me and this is a fascinating
conversation i've talked to a lot of
people about it because i'm fascinated
in this sort of as a philosophical
discussion
and and now let's talk about mac jones
the philosophical discussion is this
what is the balance now in the nfl rich
between
being able to play from the pocket and
then having to play outside of structure
is that now a necessity in the nfl
if you believe it's a necessity
philosophically
then mac jones is not your guy if you
don't believe it's a necessity but about
a luxury
and you can still function very well
without a problem
then you might really really like mac
jones mac jones is
really good in a lot of areas he's a
short strider
he's got great balance he's very quick
with where he wants to go with the
football
he's consistently precise with his ball
placement
he's very quick with with his decision
making
he's there's a lot to like about mac
jones he's just not a very good athlete
he's not going to make plays outside of
structure so if it's third and nine
in a critical moment and a critical
moment could be any time in the game
critical moments don't just happen in
the last two minutes
if it's third and nine and the defense
tactically wins
and gets a rusher right to mack jones
quickly
that plays dead so you have to decide
is that important to you is that not
important to you how important to you it
is
it's it's a philosophical question that
different
coaches i'm sure would answer
differently so
one coach um that just traded up for the
third overall selection
greg cosell i think things that he he
can scheme
somebody open and needs a quarterback
that plays
within his structure so i think i might
have the answer to the question that
prefaced your
evaluation of mack jones who do you
think well the other
other part of that equation is trey
lance right trey lance played in an
offense
where he played under center quite a bit
in fact he played in an offense for the
fullback
he is the most refined and advanced
quarterback in this draft in the
conventional play action pass game
and by conventional i mean operating
under center because he
he's done it a ton in college
quarterbacks in college today don't
normally do that
trey lance has done that more than any
of these top quarterbacks
so would you look at trey lance and say
hey he's been under center
he's played with a fullback he can fit
kyle shanahan's offense as well
uh you know we this is the fun of this
rich we're speculating
but that's you know so i don't know but
uh you're right about kyle i think
kyle is the kind of coach who believes
so strongly as many coaches do of course
believe so strongly in his system that
he believes his system
takes care of the structure defines the
reads and the throws for the quarterback
and that mac jones could well be
the kind of quarterback that he would
want and um yeah and then
before we get to justin fields then what
what is your answer to the question that
you posed
having seen all the tape of every snap
of
pretty much not only these kids but the
last several years in the nfl
uh and in years before that greg
watching the
the evolution of the game what is the
answer to your question about
the attributes of a quarterback you'd
want you know what i've gone back and
forth on that
so many times in my mind rich i mean
and i've talked to so many people people
i highly respect that you would highly
respect as well
and you know they're not sure i mean
it's it's
it's a tough deal because they're here
go to the nfc championship game okay
you had the packers and the bucks now we
know that kevin king made a bonehead
play that allowed a touchdown at the end
of the first half that should never have
happened okay
let's say that didn't happen now it did
but let's say it didn't
tom brady threw three interceptions in
the second half one of them came
when there was pressure to his front
side that was not picked up
and what did he do he just threw the
ball up for grabs that jerry alexander
intercepted
because tom brady has no response to
that and then i don't want people
listening to think oh you know you're
talking about the greatest of all time
i know who i'm talking about i'm using
that as an example of course you know he
had nothing to do
except throw the ball up you know
patrick mahomes
or another quarterback you know josh
allen they have something to do in that
situation
so it's it's a very hard question to
answer because
more than likely there will be those
situations in games
well i i mean mahomes entire super bowl
55
experience greg was was doing what he
needed to do to get out of danger
um and damn near even completed two of
the most incredible
would-be touchdowns in the history of
the biggest game you know i mean
so i i guess you can go back and forth
on
on on all of that coaches do by the way
i mean that's that's what they do it's a
hard
this stuff's not easy that that's why
you know that they make a few more bucks
than i do and then you know but they're
also in a you know more volatile
profession fortunately than i am
greg cosell nfl films producer analyst
here on the rich eisen show what is your
evaluation of justin fields
greg justin field is a super high traits
prospect i mean he's got just really
high level traits
um i think if he's the kind of
quarterback that if he puts it all
together could be absolutely sensational
um i would say this and again this is
all based on tape study i don't care
about all the noise that's irrelevant to
me
i think that he enters the league as as
i said a high level traits prospect
both as a thrower and an athlete in some
ways
he's kind of like cam newton he's just a
little smaller but he's
solidly built he's a great athlete um
i would say there's been some
inconsistency based on tape study
in what he sees in his vision in
at times in his ability to eliminate
what's not there and isolate what is
there
i always struggle to say that because i
don't know exactly how he's coached
and i'm not one who gets to sit down
with the player or speak to the to the
head coach
so i always at times i'm uncertain as to
say that
i just think the film shows that a
little bit now
do i think that these are are things
that can't be fixed no i don't
um but i think that
you have to think of it this way think
of josh allen
quarterbacks that have movement ability
it's funny we're saying this after we
just spoke about mac jones and the
balance between movement
and and pocket quarterbacks that have
great
movement ability they can make plays off
script and outside of structure
as they're learning the game and josh
allen is such a good example
you know look at the progression year
one to year two to year three
you know could justin fields be that
kind of player particularly if he has to
start early which you would
guess that he would because he'll
probably go early in the draft craig
cosell a couple more minutes left
with uh with him here senior nfl films
producer
nfl matchup analyst give me the name of
a kid that
somebody like a bears fan can hang their
hat on is that ryan pace is extolling
the virtues of andy dalton and
no no i'm i'm serious here because you
know and i
i i truly have nothing but the greatest
of respect to andy dalton and i know i
just
all disrespected him uh ad hoc which is
not fair
but i mean but but you know bears fans
are
are looking at russell wilson and and
and maybe even desean watson
and it doesn't seem like either of them
are going to be walking through that
door to use the patino phrase
but but who when you're down lower in
the first round
or you might be just sitting there in
the the back at the
front end of the second round and
trading up to go get somebody
to get a fifth year of eligibility is
there another quarterback
that you like that you think has an
upside that does require that sort of
movement in the first round
as you know when you start getting lower
uh beyond the
the sort of top is i guess it would be
top five maybe
top four or five um then you start to
deal with guys who have
some weaknesses some more defined
weaknesses right
um you know i the the quarterback
i really wish it stayed in college but i
think he's got
traits i just i he's going to need
coaching and he's going to need
experience is is davis mills
now davis mills tape he's only started
11 games
he never played a full season in college
at stanford um
he came out of the atlanta georgia area
as the number one
pocket quarterback in the country as a
high school player
there's traits there but he started 11
games
and the tape is not worthy of a high
pick
but you could easily look at him and
think i could
make this guy into a quarterback at some
point
it's just a matter of what point that is
and what the rest of the team is look
you know rich
there's so many variables involved with
quarterback play
so many and much depends on the rest of
your team well i mean that's food for
thought as i sit there with david shaw
on the first round of the uh
nfl draft coverage on nfl network i'll
file that one
he'll be able to tell you a lot more
about davis mills than i will i'm sure
i'm sure but at least it's some food for
thought uh put them on on my radar
screen for that night
uh last one for you uh one's plural uh i
don't usually do rapid fire greg but
um comp these guys for me i think you
already mentioned justin fields would
you say
cam newton's a comp for him give me some
good comps as we're a month away from
getting yeah
i don't know if he's a comp overall i
just think you know body type
athleticism you know fields is a great
athlete i mean and he throws the ball
well
uh so yeah i mean i i just thought of
that just from his body type
okay he moves so what what comp would
you have for
for trevor lawrence you got a comp for
me i don't really you know it's funny
when i do this rich
either a guy pops into my head right
away when i'm watching a player or
i don't sit around for 20 minutes after
i finish watching tape of a player
and say who does he remind me of the
either pops into my head or a dozen well
we demand comps greg so let me keep
going here maybe one pops in your head
what about zach wilson is there a comp
for him you got a comp for him
oh uh i mean you named you named like my
homes and
and he's not at that rock full of arm
talent i mean he's got like i said he's
got a live
arm and he moves well and he'll make
some throws that are that are
really nice but i don't think he's quite
at that level of armed talent
i know some people think that um but he
plays like that
you know the thing about mahomes and you
know this
and it's easy now to say oh everybody
was an idiot
but don't forget mahomes was the 10th
pick in the draft the chiefs traded up
to get him i remember being at the
combine that year speaking to
really respected offensive coaches in
the league who were very concerned about
the reckless undisciplined way mahomes
played in college
now wilson has a little of that to his
game as well but we've seen how mahomes
has played out in the league
he's with a great coach as well so we'll
see how it plays out with wilson but
he's got that
kind of looseness to his movement as
well greg thanks for the call
appreciate it maybe we'll tap on your
shoulder uh in the next couple of weeks
right before the draft get your final
thoughts i really appreciate it always
oh rich thanks so much appreciate it you
got it guys greg cosell not only is he
just
got such a keen eye but real quick the
insight that he just gave you at the end
there
at the combine speaking to highly
respected people
who are concerned about mahomes ability
to play in control a little bit too wild
thrown into certain windows and a lot of
coaches are like
i don't want any part of that and then
there's andy reid saying oh i coach
brett favre i want that
exactly you know what i mean like that
and thus now
a dynasty has a possibility of being
born unbelievable hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here